this is what it's all about the daily
arrival of asylum seekers
growing numbers are making this
treacherous crossing but also growing is
objection to the government's plan to
send migrants to rwanda
the home secretary has hit back
writing in the times with the rwandan
foreign minister priti patel says we are
taking bold and innovative steps and
it's surprising that those institutions
that criticize the plans fail to offer
their own solutions
and solutions are hard to find as the
influx of small boats shows
we have a position now where last year
twenty eight thousand five hundred
people across the channel illegally into
this country uh that compares to just
three hundred in twenty eighteen the
government is taking tough action here
and sending a very clear message that it
won't be possible
to
go through those people smugglers
but some say the plan won't deter
crossings or human traffickers labor
says a better system for asylum claims
is needed
the problem we have at the moment is if
you are not a ukrainian and i mean let's
not even begin to talk about how complex
and slow that process has been but if
you're not a ukrainian if you're not an
afghan
and if you're not from syria it's really
unclear how you can
have any route to claim asylum
here's where migrants will be sent but
who knows when or even if they'll arrive
one leading immigration lawyer says the
whole idea is unlawful i think there's
going to be a number of individual
challenges but there's also going to be
probably some larger challenge to the
scheme itself particularly around the
fact that i think well we know it
breaches international agreements which
are effectively taking up and so tearing
up and saying we don't want to be part
of this anymore and i think it's highly
highly discriminatory
the home secretary will make a statement
on tuesday meanwhile crossings continue
and there's a worry the plans will panic
even more to make the journey laura
bundock sky news